you've got Republicans in office who are
uh
already tiating against support for
Ukraine and uh and now everybody's focus
on what focus on what's going on in the
Middle East so uh where do you think
this is going what do you want how how
do you look at it well here's how I look
at it it circles back to this idea of
power who who do we wanted to have been
and what do we want the result of who we
were to be for our children for
generations to come we are
disavowing any claim of loving our
children if we allow these things to go
forward we're just saying you I don't
care because I want to be a big shot now
and being a big shot now is I'm going to
say we're America only we know we were
never America only right that doesn't
work it doesn't work and and that's and
it's true on the left also all of those
people who are you know I'm not sure
maybe I'm with Robert Kennedy Junior who
says we shouldn't go in there well
godamn you I'll tell you I know exactly
where you're going to be you're going to
be the who's standing out there with a
sign on behalf of The Starving in North
Africa in two years from now saying
we've got to help these people how do
you think they got in trouble you got
three feet of black soil in Ukraine that
that feeds the that half of that
continent and now you can't get to that
and it can't get to you and you're
complaining because you said we're Hawks
so it's time to like buck up and say
what's the what's really going on here
um no question Putin will not stop if
he's allowed to go on um why would he
and the question is asked very clearly
by people who know more than I do in the
film um and then when we get caught up
in you know what the media thing is so
you had just had this horror show
ongoing horror show in Israel get inv
involved because these people are
involved on your behalf that's right and
there's the other part of it the pushing
leaderships to
acknowledge the parts of their
history or in some cases current
policies that encourage some of the bad
action so you've got to when the time
comes in the time of your life to kill
these
militants have to be killed this ugly
horror show that doesn't mean there
aren't some very serious things to be
looked at
within those you know those who are
being attacked
leadership same in the United States we
can think two things right I remember a
fantasy I had of George
Bush after 911 I thought you you know
just just man just get up there look in
the camera and tell America what you're
going to do because you've already you
haven't asked anybody's permission and
you've told the White House Council stay
out of your life for a week and you're
ready to go to jail if you're violating
some law but
unilaterally you've got special
operators in toror right
now and um we're going to kill them
we're going to kill every one of them
and I'll go to jail for it if I have to
because that's my
job but now we also got to start looking
at how we affect extreme poverty around
the world and create the fertile ground
for this kind of
evil you know I think we just got to
make
trendy a little bit of nuanced
thought a little bit of the ability to
to look at both sides of a thing without
being accused of somehow being an
apologist
for uh you know
one one absence of good for
another but at the same time calling
evil evil there has to be a line that
you don't get forgi there's nothing more
powerful in this world than forgiveness
man and and and yeah I say call it evil
when it's when it's productive to do
that it's the same thing I think about
when I you know I hear these people
who's constituencies are solid for them
uh and it's very hip that they call
thems a
socialist well you know I I always to
think about that that if uh if your
granny can call 9111 when she hears
somebody breaking into her house and the
police come that's kind of a good thing
right and that's something we can all
granny was saved because she could call
911 then the question I have for people
who get out you know all scared of
socialism then is which credit card did
she use to pay them when they let
yeah yeah yeah yeah
so there were times that you know it's
such an Indulgence to use words that we
know are inflammatory right let's take
Israel for example yeah I I don't think
I'd be
satisfied if nobody was calling it
evil but I'm very grateful that there
are some who are just being more sober
than to use any kind of uh word that
somehow to other people
may show that you're not getting it I
mean one of the things that I'm sort of
left paralyzed with now is who the [__]
is going to lead us out of this who who
are they who is the person I do think
that the that that look we're not all
leaders on that level and um we're not
all leaders in in in even in small parts
of our Lives some of us are most of us
hope to be and all of us are responsible
to be but not everybody succeeds at this
for various reasons but I do think the
leaders are going to be
dominantly before noticing let's
say that Putin is
evil which like that's how that's my
level I don't know that someone like
zalinski needs to take it that
far but zalinsky feels and I saw it in
him and it was it was so refreshing and
I think it speaks to his leadership his
inherent gift and courage and
clear-mindedness as leader
calm he says you
know he's not very
interesting yeah that's what he says
about Bo great and you sit there and you
say I want to hear what else you got to
say cuz that's true I just realized
that's true it sort of reminds me Bowski
had had a poem about I saw a genius I
met a genius and you know he's riding
the rail from Los Angeles to San Diego
and you know this ocean it's what it is
this section ocean depends on the sky
that day or the this but and we tell
ourselves oh it's beautiful it's
beautiful the ocean's beautiful and he's
riding the rail with a seven-year-old
kid and the kid looks at him at a
certain point they're both looking out
the window of the train kid looks at him
he
says it's not
beautiful to which Bowski responds in
the poem was the first time I realized
that so good you and I think so yeah I
think that in in a way that can speak
to the
genuiness of this particular leader
zinski I I've never seen him spin
anything I've never seen him
rehearse
or or that there's a show of a
rehearsal he in you know in person
talking to him there's
no you know I understand that somebody's
trying to sell something whether it's a
policy or or a pineapple you know they
they had you spend enough time with them
you're going to run into their script
yeah he's learning more every day
there's no that was an old script yeah
incredibly fast
[Music]
study